Nos dicen que en cierto momento de un juego
de basquetbol, un jugador se encuentra a 5
metros del centro de la canasta; la distancia
del suelo a los ojos del jugador es de 1.75
metros. Observa la figura. En ese instante,
¿cuál es el valor del ángulo de elevación
entre los ojos del jugador y el aro de la
canasta? Si observamos con cuidado la figura
que se forma entre la altura de la canasta,
la altura que hay hasta los ojos del jugador
y su distancia a la canasta, podemos ver que
tenemos el siguiente triángulo rectángulo.
Y antes de resolver el problema, recordemos las
características de los triángulos rectángulos.
Aquí tenemos un triángulo rectángulo; lo sabemos
porque uno de sus ángulos mide 90 grados y lo
identificamos con un cuadrado. El ángulo de 90
grados es el ángulo más grande de un triángulo
rectángulo. A los lados del triángulo les
llamaremos a, b y c; al lado opuesto del ángulo de
90 grados, c, también se le llama Hipotenusa, y es
el lado más largo de un triángulo rectángulo; los
lados a y b, que son más cortos que c, es decir,
que son más cortos que la Hipotenusa, reciben
el nombre de catetos. Recordemos el teorema de
Pitágoras, que establece una relación entre las
longitudes de los lados de un triángulo rectángulo
y nos ayuda a calcular la longitud de un lado de
un triángulo rectángulo si conocemos la longitud
de los otros dos. El Teorema de Pitágoras nos dice
que la suma del cuadrado de las longitudes de
los catetos, a² + b², es igual al cuadrado de
la longitud de la Hipotenusa, c². Este teorema
nos va a ser muy útil para resolver el problema
que tenemos aquí, pero antes vamos a definir las
razones que podemos obtener de las longitudes de
los lados de los triángulos rectángulos, y las
llamaremos razones trigonométricas. Una razón
trigonométrica es el cociente entre las longitudes
de dos de los lados de un triángulo rectángulo con
respecto a uno de sus ángulos agudos, es decir,
cualquiera de estos dos ángulos del triángulo
que tenemos aquí. Es importante observar que las
razones trigonométricas son cantidades numéricas
o adimensionales, es decir, que no poseen
unidades. Vamos a definir las seis razones
trigonométricas que existen entre las longitudes
de dos de los lados de un triángulo rectángulo,
y digamos que alfa (α) es el ángulo agudo de
nuestro triángulo rectángulo que vamos a usar para
hacerlo. También podríamos usar este otro ángulo
agudo, es decir, las razones trigonométricas se
establecen para cualquiera de los ángulos agudos
del triángulo, pero para esta explicación usaremos
alfa. La primera razón trigonométrica que vamos
a definir es el seno de alfa, y el Sen α = a la
longitud del cateto opuesto a α entre la longitud
de la hipotenusa. Este lado a es el cateto opuesto
al ángulo α y esta es la hipotenusa. Enseguida
definiremos el coseno de alfa (Cos α), que es
igual a la longitud del cateto adyacente a α
dividida entre la longitud de la hipotenusa;
este lado que tenemos aquí es el cateto
adyacente al ángulo α, y esta es la hipotenusa,
como ya lo hemos visto. Luego tenemos la tangente
de alfa (Tan α), que es igual a la longitud del
cateto opuesto a α entre la longitud del cateto
adyacente a α. La siguiente razón trigonométrica
que vamos a definir es la cotangente de alfa
(Cot α), que es la razón inversa a la tangente
y es igual a la longitud del cateto adyacente
a α entre la longitud del cateto opuesto a α.
Enseguida tenemos la secante de alfa (Sec α),
que es igual a la longitud de la hipotenusa entre
la longitud del cateto adyacente α. Esta razón
trigonométrica es inversa al coseno. Por último,
definiremos la cosecante de alfa (Csc α), que es
la razón inversa al seno de alfa y es igual a la
longitud de la hipotenusa entre la longitud del
cateto opuesto. A partir del triángulo que tenemos
aquí vamos a escribir los valores de las razones
trigonométricas que hemos definido. El Sen α es
igual al cateto opuesto que, en el caso de nuestro
triángulo, es a entre la hipotenusa que es c,
de modo que el Sen α = a / c. El Cos α es igual
al cateto adyacente que es b, entre la hipotenusa,
el cos = b / c. Enseguida tenemos la Tan
α, que es igual al cateto opuesto que es a,
entre el cateto adyacente que es b, la Tan
α = a / b. Luego, para calcular el valor de
las razones inversas, tenemos que la Cot
α es igual al cateto adyacente que es b,
entre el cateto opuesto que es a, la cot = b / a,
la razón inversa a la tangente. A continuación la
Sec α es igual a c, que es la hipotenusa, entre
el cateto adyacente que es b, la Sec α = c / b. Y,
por último, el valor de la Csc α = c / a,
que es la hipotenusa entre el cateto opuesto.
A continuación vamos a hacer un ejemplo para
obtener las seis razones trigonométricas respecto
al ángulo alfa de nuestro triángulo rectángulo.
En esta figura vemos que el tercer lado se calcula
con el Teorema de Pitágoras; así tenemos que
a² + 15² = 17², restamos 15² de los dos lados
y nos queda que a² = 17² - 15²; resolvemos
por diferencia de cuadrados y esto es igual
a (17 - 15) (17 + 15), 17 - 15 = 2 y 17
+ 15 = 32, 2 * 32 = 64, así que a² = 64,
y obtenemos la raíz cuadrada positiva de 64 y
el resultado es 8: a = 8. Luego tenemos que el
cateto opuesto a alfa es igual a 8, el cateto
adyacente alfa es igual a 15 y la hipotenusa es
igual a 17. Con estos valores podemos obtener las
razones trigonométricas respecto al ángulo alfa:
el Sen α es igual al cateto opuesto que es 8 / 17,
que es el valor de la hipotenusa; el Cos α = 15 /
17, cateto adyacente entre hipotenusa; la Tan α
= 8 / 15, cateto opuesto entre cateto adyacente;
la cotangente es inversa a la tangente, así
que es igual a 15 / 8; la secante es igual
a la hipotenusa entre el cateto adyacente, es
decir 17 / 15, y por último la Csc = 17 / 8,
que es la hipotenusa entre el cateto opuesto.
Podemos hacer algunas observaciones a las razones
trigonométricas que hemos estudiado hasta este
momento. Como la hipotenusa c es mayor que los
catetos a y b, entonces el seno y el coseno de
un ángulo agudo son menores que 1 pero mayores
que 0. Así podemos decir que 0 ˂ Sen α, que es
menor que 1, y 0 ˂ Cos α que es menor que 1;
asimismo la secante y la cosecante son mayores
que 1: la Sec α ˃ 1 y la Csc α ˃ 1. Para las
razones trigonométricas tangente y contangente,
un cateto puede ser mayor que otro cateto,
incluso pueden ser iguales, que es un caso,
que no se da entre un cateto y la hipotenusa,
entonces la tangente y la cotangente son
mayores que 0: la Tan α ˃ 0 y la Cot α ˃
0. Una vez revisado el Teorema de Pitágoras y
las razones trigonométricas, regresemos a la
resolución de nuestro problema original. Como
lo vimos anteriormente al observar con cuidado
la figura que se forma entre la altura de la
canasta, la altura que hay hasta los ojos del
jugador y su distancia a la canasta, podemos ver
que tenemos el siguiente triángulo rectángulo.
Calculemos el valor de sus lados: la altura
de la canasta es 3 m y la altura hasta los
ojos del jugador es de 1.75 m, así que a = 3
- 1.75, es decir, a = 1.25. Con el Teorema de
Pitágoras podemos calcular el valor de c: a²
+ b² = c²; 1.25² + 5² = c², 1.25² = 1.56 + 5²,
que es 25, es igual a c²; c² = 26.56. Obtenemos
la raíz cuadrada de 26.56 y la raíz positiva es
igual a 5.15, de modo que hemos obtenido los
siguientes valores: cateto opuesto a α = 1.25;
cateto adyacente a α = 5; hipotenusa = 5.15.
Ahora podemos usar cualquiera de las razones
trigonométricas para obtener el valor del ángulo
alfa que es lo que nos piden. Usemos el seno de
alfa: el valor del Sen α = 1.25 / 5.15, esto es
igual a 0.2427. En la siguiente tabla tenemos
el valor del seno de algunos ángulos: el seno
de un ángulo de 10 grados es igual a 0.1736,
el seno de un ángulo de 11 grados es igual a
0.1908, y así sucesivamente, por lo que podemos
estimar que nuestro ángulo alfa es aproximadamente
de 14 grados. El seno de un ángulo de 14 grados
es igual a 0.2419, y el valor del seno que
calculamos es de 0.2427. El valor del ángulo
de elevación entre los ojos del jugador y el aro
de la canasta es aproximadamente de 14 grados.